hey what's up guys welcome to this
week's show I am extremely extremely
extremely excited because I am sat down
with the Patricia bright now if you
don't know who Patricia Brite is she's
one of the original o.g youtubers
she's been youtubing for a very long
time been really inspirational to me if
you want to check a book out this is an
incredible book called heart and hustle
and other reason I've got Patricia oil
is because she did a video on her
channel quite recently about property
and I just thought she's a massive
influencer incredibly inspiring female
leyde investing in property I have to
get on my show so Patricia thank you for
coming down to the to the show it's
great to have you here thank you for
having me watch me a little bit of
background about what you do yeah about
that video that you put out there that
promise a that so many people watched
and I know it might look a bit weird for
me being on this channel because
obviously I do YouTube I make videos on
beauty and fashion and I've been a full
time youtuber for like the last say
seven years a buff and I started doing
this if what was even a career it wasn't
really a thing because I used to work a
full-time job and then I did this on the
side but I've always kind of been into
one being kind of smart with my money
and then the idea of investing I did
that video just because at the I think
was at the beginning of the year we
decided to pay off that house entirely
so put cash down but actually it's a bit
of a convoluted way we sold that house
to our company so we have a holding
company and so I still own the property
and the rent it out but I thought it
would be interesting and inspirational
to maybe do a video and how I paid off
my mortgage but I didn't go into lots of
details and there was a lot of questions
about it and your name was brought up a
lot yeah there's actually someone who
did like a reaction video was like I
don't think she paid off her mortgage I
think something or the other
I watched Samuel Leeds and he talks
about this kind of stuff so actually I
think that is how I found out about you
or maybe I've seen your videos before
then yes I'm into saving money being
good with money and then into poverty as
well so what was the general reaction
from that property video cuz your your I
don't know would you
so you were on a makeup you really known
for makeup or just lifestyle exactly
you've got how many how many subscribers
on YouTube now so I've got 2.8 million
followers on YouTube and it's mainly
women around the world who love beauty
who love fashion I'm also a mum and
actually when I first started my youtube
channel I was working so I used to work
in investment banking and I worked in
consulting so I would do videos of me
like getting ready to go to work and
here's my work uniform and I'd have a
backpack on so a lot of girls knew me
for being the career girl I talked about
my jobs and that kind of thing so
there's a balance of girls who love just
you know products but girls who also are
interested in you know improving their
lives all yeah being career driven I've
got a lot of career goals and you know
your your whole brand and start is
people know that you're an inspiring
you're a businesswoman you're not just
you are you're a businesswoman you smile
and you can do good with money so you
know what was the reaction to that video
generally was it very positive it was
very very positive there's an element of
confusion and people also not entirely
understanding how it's possible I might
use to see comments of people saying
well that's because you're a youtuber
only you can do that and that was one of
the things that would bug me because I I
would respond to comment I said no not
only me does this I like I come from
immigrant background my mom's a hustler
and she's done it so it's not just cuz I
was a youtuber I was able to pay off a
property it's just because yeah I made a
lot of money do moms done really well
though yeah yeah she's kind of slowing
down now selling a lot of stuff and just
try to live her bed you sent your video
she came into the UK as new grown yeah
and now she has 10 houses in the UK
exactly it just shows that you can start
with nothing but if you're prepared to
hustle your bed to work hard yeah and
anything really is clean if you're smart
about news that you make and you're able
to learn about how this stuff works
and actually what I started quite early
so my mum I think she went onto a
property course or she'd met someone who
was into it who told her to buy a house
she had a council property I bought it
for 17,000 and then sold it for 250,000
and then used that money to buy other
houses
and so I was with her during that whole
journey so I watched her when I was like
15 kind of go from zero to like Oh to
all of this so I knew it was very
possible and then I used to manage her
properties in Manchester when I was at
uni so she had four properties and I
would be writing contracts and going to
see tenants and all this kind of stuff
so I was obviously having fun at uni but
I was also doing this as well so I was
very familiar with the process and a new
day was possible yeah for sure
and you know just it wasn't just that
one house you've gone on to buy more
houses and now you're a property
investor Patricia the property investor
I kind of I haven't shared much about
that and I'm very new to I want to say
new to doing it myself but I don't I
don't know all the details of doing an
show you're like the expert I've seen
you doing this like the houses of
multiple occupancy yeah yeah these are
the technical stuff but I'm like I don't
even know what this is to me that you
said to me just before we start the
internet off camera I might maybe I'm
doing a bit wrong but no but the thing
is you know you're probably not doing it
as maximum and getting as much
properties you could be but hey if
you're buying property yes a pretty safe
and you smile and you know you're not
doing it with all your feelings but you
know you've done really well with what
you've done so far so I think respect
and it's great to see you doing it and
one of the one of the reasons I've
wanted you on this channel I said this
to you is because ninety percent in fact
just over 90 percent of my audience on
YouTube oh man
right and that kind of ticks me off a
little bit okay because I want to see
your channel I know you you've got like
over 90% of women watch one of the men
is actually me now but I just thought
you know I want I want to inspire I
inspire a lot of guys mhm
a lot of young men as well because I'm
young myself so a lot of young guys to
get into poverty but I just want I want
women to see that it's possible to and
all women to be inspired and I want them
to step up and you mentioned that the
pay difference between men and women men
used to get paid a lot more and now
that's beginning to change in fact maybe
I can swing a little bit yes for me that
I think that's really inspiring and
empowering to women so I mean what are
your thoughts on that
I mean I think that it's not even just
that the pay difference is changing I
think it's that women aren't working
more in higher earning jobs as well so
you know there were the time where women
could have work and all this kind of
stuff or they only did maybe more lower
paying jobs Bartley well they couldn't
even vote yeah exactly I mean we don't
know about like exactly not even that
far but even the choices of jobs we
picked are a bit more different I think
so you know taking up engineering jobs
and drums in sciences and you know me
working in finance as there weren't that
many women I was in an all-male tilt
team especially within technology but
more of us are taking those
opportunities and not just the ones that
are a bit more lower paying and
personally I think a bit smarter when it
comes to money they just didn't have as
much access to it but now they do so
it's a great thing especially if there's
balance as well and men I mean if you're
in a relationship when you have men who
help out at home it makes a huge
difference what you're doing now
you know inspiring other people but
really strong personal brand do you
think you're born like that or is this
stuff that you thought I want to do that
and then you had to had to learn and yet
to push yourself or was this just a
natural I think it's 50/50 I think it's
born
so people have different personality
types either my sister were raised in
the same house we're like polar
opposites yeah and she saw the exact
same things that I saw and was raised a
exact same way as I was raised but we're
very different but she also works on my
company and she's she gets stuff done in
her own way but I think there's also
like once you can educate yourself and
learn it's your choice to make take
action and do something about it so for
me it was seeing my mom's journey always
made me know that okay I can do whatever
I want to do yeah and it is definitely
possible and then I really made sure
that I Drive really hard to get what I
want
yeah but that's also like a personality
type yeah okay so with this property
then you put the video out okay you have
loads of people asking questions about
it now presumably I might be wrong did
part of you always want to do another
video but then you didn't want to keep
you in lots of property videos so now is
your chance
you're now yeah now you tell it to talk
property yeah answer all those questions
yeah give as much figures
you want yeah and and and and you know
I'm well interested I'm sorry my
accountant to tell me I would say that
no so what so what I've done yeah so I
had a lot of cash so I didn't want to
say I've got a lot of cash but I had low
cash I have a lot of cash to see what I
wanted exactly
I'm cash rich so the choice was what do
I do with my cash and might as well put
it into something such as and also try
and reduce my tax that was my main kind
of goal
so my I also wanted to move house so
what I knew is that we bought this house
three hundred and ten thousand pounds
and it we know that the area had gone up
in value so we bought it I think in 2000
and was it 12 I think and it's in watts
per park which is right next to
Wimbledon that was yeah it was a really
did you guys the night probably
absolutely cry yeah thousand twelve it
was just aa yeah
and that's cuz we had a decent deposit
and this is the fall like me and my
husband had extra cash but we were just
he was a physiotherapist I was working
my job but we still had enough money
like fifteen fifteen percent deposit so
that was just as very normal 26 year
olds yeah I don't know if every normal
26 year old has that much money but he
had actually bought a house in
Manchester two years or four four eighty
thousand no hit I think he bought it for
fifty thousand and sold it for ninety
thousand so that helped us put a little
bit of money down for the deposit and
staffing and I was earning so we had 15%
to put down on the house no it's like
yes there is sixty thousand fifty
thousand is a lot to like everything but
yeah fifty thousand is what we put down
yeah
and that was at the age of 26 27 yeah
and then we did up the house we did a
loft conversion and then we had the
house valued at about six hundred and
ten thousand pounds and we wanted to
move and actually you spend on the house
in total probably about said sixty to
seventy thousand euros oh it's 70 so you
might have for three times yes in
seventy on it
that's 380 in total yeah and then have
it valued down the line at 640 yes yeah
yeah exactly in value and so the choices
you ever sell it on the open market and
to get that money back so that was
personal money or I could sell it to my
company and take that money cash and
keep that personally because we wanted
to buy a new house so we bought a more
expensive house and we put the 300,000
whatever we got in terms of appreciation
we use that as our deposit for our new
house which is a much bigger much more
expensive house and so but we still own
that house rule under our holding
company yeah you right some people
didn't understand that right no we just
the company had cash the company bought
the house from us as individuals and
then us as individuals took that maybe
to put deploy yeah really weird or dodgy
exactly the holding company that we are
the owners of own the property so say me
my from an individual to it which is
going to be more tax efficient yes
exactly so us as individuals we don't
own that house but our company's own
that hassle and so we've gone on to then
the money that that company has has then
bought another two or three properties
yeah know how many more we bought two
more properties and you buy two at the
moment no we've already bought them they
already bought their company one has
been done and already rent or more in
the pipeline hopefully maybe one more
before the end of the year my goal is to
buy two a year so I'm a cash buyer yeah
I don't know if that's a good thing well
I don't like I know yeah that 50,000
pound that you put down I know and when
you were like oh you know what really
half of that most people haven't got
that yeah if you do someone else's fifty
thousand yeah you just don't make the
same massive profits I great so yes that
that's the and that's what I what I do
yeah and even people you know people
really rich people they're not debt free
yeah I don't really know yeah they're
free so there's anything wrong with with
buying it cash for some people yeah if
they sleep better right now I doing that
and they're in a position with
a business where they can and they don't
want to be multi multi multi
millionaires is it wrong with that but
if you want to grow really big yeah then
you will need to leverage you also need
to have a place to put cash so if I've
got lots of cash it's sitting in the
bank with zero percent interest I rather
put that cash in a property and get five
or seven percent interest and if I want
to pull the money out of the property at
some point in time I can do that yeah
and that's the plan at some point in
time if I really need to draw equity out
of these properties I can I just don't
have anything that I want to do with it
just yet and I also don't want to have
lots and lots and lots and lots and lots
of properties yeah because it's too
spotty stressful yeah I think because
you can just go into bigger deals like
commercial for instance right yeah where
you have 20 year leases to companies and
you don't have to deal with tenants know
anything about the world is your oyster
you know at least what you're doing is
way better than putting in the bank
where you guys Eero interest the money
is shrinking because they're printing
money all the time is that key you know
makes sense I think you didn't really
work memory smart and I hope that you
inspire lots of other people to me
influences branders talk to me about
your course I don't know if you
currently have one of your bouncer so I
had one specifically that I launched
this year yeah it was called the break
and this was specifically about being a
social media I gotta do this person I'm
gonna do it right
yeah you should I think everyone should
definitely do it if they are interested
in this space and I did it based on the
fact that I would speak to a lot of
girls in the industry specific usually
girls who had no idea on how the
business actually works one how'd you
get deals how'd you manage your deals
how do you schedule stuff how do you
reach out to clients and what's a media
pack all these different things that I
spent a long time learning how to
basically do so I put that into a course
anyone who is thinking about becoming a
social media esque person yeah here's a
blueprint on the things that you should
do and then some tools and resources
that make it use that's awesome and from
as a personal media
sorry social-media influencer Brander
like there's no one that's kind of doing
it like you are in the UK
you are killing it and not only you do
really well but you've been doing it for
a very long time that's why I want to
introduce like one of the og yeah you
know and all I think as well from an
investment in a property point of view
lot I do both my personal brand is
nowhere near like yours right ya know
and my following is nowhere near like
yours I've got just over one hundred and
twelve thousand subscribers on YouTube
that's done a lot of numbers yeah it is
it is but but the crazy thing is I
really believe that you should do both
and I think that if you can have a
strong personal brand and then invest
well yes and be a good business person
yeah you are gonna be able to help a lot
of people have and ultimately I think
when you make a lot of money mm-hmm
you may think a lot money because you're
helping other people yes I feel bad
about a great agreed do you really I
agree with it as long as it's in balance
like it's a case of if you can help
people without them having to give you
something so my thing is I want to
provide advice and all this stuff
without me having to get anything they
want to give me something if they want
it to pay for that's how it works that's
how it works exactly the thing is I
don't know if you know Gary Vaynerchuk
yeah that you cannot grow a successful
business without first giving lots of
value yeah so and the more value you
give the more people are going to be
like well if I had that much for free
you've already changed my life then it's
so easy to then how about monetizing
compactive as where help people even
more so um so from I think that as a
property investor like if you're wanting
to do deals with people for me it's
really easy to do deals because most
estate agents and people know who I am
and I've got a reputation they know who
I am
so it's really easy for me and people
say you've got an unfair advantage I
haven't got unfair advantage I've made a
deliberate effort to put myself out
there on social media every time I buy a
house document it vlog the journey
publish the figures yeah so that people
can see okay I know what this person is
doing but then when I want to joint
venture with people when I want to raise
finance when I want to package and sell
deals or whatever it might be I have the
best accountant solicitors brokers
commit willing to do business you've
made just because it's like what can I
go on your channel or I trust you
because I've watched seven
of you content yes so I want your
business of you and what I wouldn't
think I'm trying to encourage my guys to
do is put themselves out there more yes
build a personal brand yes and there's
no better person to ask
the top three piece of advice on this
Danny yeah so three top things for my
guys property investors what should they
be doing to build their personal brand
in Minnesota I'm gonna say one thing I
don't think everyone is made for the
camera okay fair enough some people
their personal brand might be the things
that they write about okay it might be
their what they do an audio it might be
something that they create and their
product is known more than their now so
I've seen this happen a lot in our space
that there are people that they're not
known but their product has such a
strong rep there's a brown cord like
summer fridays this is like a
moisturizer brand and it was created by
an influencer she's not that big but her
brand is massive and its really trust
her brand yeah well and some of us you
know you know low-key know who she is
but not the majority of people yeah so
you know personal branding doesn't have
to just be sit in front of the camera
yeah it can be just create something
really valuable yeah business Oh promote
a business a product or service and then
I'd say I always say consistency is its
King people thought oh you know you just
made it now I've been doing this for 10
years
so I didn't just come out of nowhere
I've just I've been here doing what I do
regularly do you know when her videos
gonna go viral do you think this one's
gonna be viral I know how to make a
viral video I just don't always want to
do it because I'm actually yeah yeah you
don't need to always be viral so last
year I had a really viral yay so I went
from 1 million to 1.5 million in one
year and I did a bunch of videos that
will constantly viral how do you make a
video go viral well you can't make it go
viral but what's the magic potion what's
the trick
honesty something dramatic happening and
something that it is on trend so when I
had my viral season there was a brand
that people who are quite famous with
wearing and I did a really honest
transparent like not diss but like is
this what
Kylie Jenner talks about all the time
video and then I created a series and
then so every one of those videos were
doing five million views and then
everybody else on the platform started
doing those videos but I accidentally
stumbled on that viral five million view
video yeah it was like I didn't plan for
it to be viral sure it went viral and
then when it did I did ten other videos
that were of the exact same formula so
those did find me six million seven
million
yeah two million and that's what helped
me because so cause it was right if I
seen some things done really well create
a series yeah so figure out number one
do you want to be on camera
yes what all you want to write or do you
want to document a business or whatever
it might be yeah and then put out
consistent good content that value and
try and jump on the back of trends yes
I'm not in a cringy way yeah yeah trend
hunting way because sure thing that I
think makes the most is the way that
someone that really has a personal brand
is authenticity
nice don't be fake don't try and be
someone else
don't try and just be on a wave because
it's a way to beyond like it that
actually is less available it doesn't
work as well being you yell at my videos
I don't even I've never tried to follow
trends it's not something I've done I
think the reason I get I've got a
hundred twelve thousand subscribers is
because I just I just document
everything I'm doing yeah and I just put
out a video every single day Wow is
consistent I have six full-time
videographers so it's like really really
hardcore okay so I would recommend
people read this book for sure how do we
figure out if we were if some of my guys
want to maybe go on your online course
or what would you suggest they do how do
they follow you out what can I listen
I'm the worst sales person ever I don't
even know what I've got going on I mean
my book can be found on Amazon heartless
also it's also in where is it where is
this book it's in you never plug this
though you videos no I'm not I'm not I
said I'm not a salesperson you're
robbing people of the experience but
we've got great sells there's a lot of
people who die every single day someone
arts and shows me this book that they're
reading it on holiday that they're in an
air
like some people are always sharing this
with me and you know I did I did promote
it when it first came out it's in
waterstones it sold in America so it's
an official but you know it's published
by HarperCollins so if people want it
they can find it these don't people
people get it because you put out so
much good stuff for free you're mostly
you almost don't need to sell yeah I
mean the thing is is I know who my
audience is yeah so right now my
audience is mainly girls who want to
know about new fashion products and new
clothing products and then once in the
world they want to hear about other
stuff so if I was to start going on
about my book called going on about
poverty that's not the audience that has
got but they're all gonna be people
within that audience who want to know
about this stuff because I know that you
know if I've done that video about
poverty when are you gonna launch you
know channels it was nine months you've
mentioned it nine months you are I'm
gonna do any time we're still waiting oh
my gosh it is that is pressure does that
you know that I'm hoping that as a
result of meeting me today we launched
sister so we've already done the podcast
and you've got a six person camera team
it's just me and like two other people
we've got a me know as well but you know
it's just trying to make everything work
I've just launched a new product
collaboration I've had a clothing
collaboration this year with Amazon
Rosen I have got what else I've got so
much going on that just trying to
balance that it's gonna be lots of free
content just making time for it is
difficult but it's launching mid
November mid-november Eddy shot the
contents is good before before baby yes
hopefully I'll be introducing the baby
on touch an award loved a dog's body
shot it so Super Bowl it's been really
cool came to me a little bit and thank
you so much get the book fine Patricia
follower on Lauren and hope to see you
again real soon
thank you amazing
[Music]